les parlementaires ont donc fait leur
rentrée cette semaine le 11 septembre
nous avons suivi les premiers pas à
l'assemblée de françois de mazières le
maire de versailles soutenu par l'ump le
candidat divers droite avait été élu en
juin dernier il a succédé à etienne
tente lui aussi ump qui était élu depuis
plus de vingt ans comment prend t'il lui
ses marques dans l'opposition reportage
anthony rech et elodie moines
à l'assemblée nationale la salle des
quatre colonnes est en effervescence une
semaine après l'école les députés font
leur rentrée plus tôt que prévu une
reprise plutôt tendue dans laquelle un
nouveau député comme françois de
mazières député maire de versailles
pourrait se sentir perdus au milieu des
rouages parlementaire on a très vite ses
repères vous savez d'abord il se trouve
que je suis par mon propre parcours
puisque j'ai été
sous préfet j'ai été membre de cabinet
ministériel il se trouve que je connais
le fonctionnement du parlement donc
quand vous arrivez vous à bord très bien
accueilli et vous avez très rapidement
les repères nécessaires
fait rare pour un nouveau député
françois de mazières pose une question
au gouvernement sur le dossier brûlant
de la loi sru dessin première séance
officielle d'une multiplication par 5
des sanctions retrait nnerait 4 dérive
la première c'est le poids
disproportionné des sanctions élu aux
dernières élections législatives le
député-maire yvelinois sans étiquette
apparenté ump débute sa carrière au sein
de l'opposition et il assure que ses
deux mandats sont compatibles c'est pas
du tout compliqué quand vous êtes proche
de paris comment voyez j'ai la chance
d'être à 20 minutes entre les deux
bureaux et c'est non c'est non pas
compliqué mais c'est vraiment utile
simple les interventions que je peux
faire sont nourris de l'expérience de
terrain cette double étiquette se fera
probablement au projet de loi sur le
non-cumul des mandats voulue par le
président hollande en attendant françois
de mazières partage son temps entre
l'assemblée et sa commune de versailles
bonsoir donc jean-michel fourgous maire
d'elancourt ump ancien député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines battu en
juin dernier par benoît hamon vous êtes
toujours à l'ump vous redécouvrez donc
ce statut d'opposition le statut
d'opposant comment vous le vivez
actuellement justement on est un peu
d'alternance de ce sens et n'est pas est
plutôt sain pour la démocratie donc
c'est bien d'abord de voir que nous nous
collègues socialistes donc découvre un
peu la crise découvre les contraintes de
l'économie de marché des entreprises qui
qui qui bien sûr souffrent dans cette
seconde guerre mondiale économique il
faut presque répétée comme ça donc
écouter c'est intéressant de voir que
tous les français participent à ces aux
réalités économiques voilà dire bon
chine ont coûté moi je suis toujours
maire d'elancourt puis comme une ville
de près de trente mille habitants c'est
un mandat qu'un important c'est
passionnant et je me bats sur la lutte
contre l'échec scolaire pour la voilà ce
que c'est difficile de se faire entendre
justement lorsqu'on n'est plus député ne
se faire entendre pour sa commune
également d'obtenir des choses pour sa
commune alors goûté je l' ai pas vécu
pour l'instant parce que au fait que les
gens ne connaissent dans le réseau
illinois et puis et puis oui ce jeu est
un des spécialistes en corner nationaux
sur le plan de la réussite scolaire du
de la lutte contre l'échec scolaire
j'étais chez un habitant des colloques
nationaux ou internationaux
donc je sais je ne le vis pas trop et
sur l'économie je travaille un peu avec
les djs aussi sur la pédagogie
l'économie et au travers du bien fondé
un groupe à l'assemblée lors de la
précédente mandature au travers de ce
groupe qui s'appelle génération
entreprise qui relançait qui existent
aujourd'hui qu'ils existent et dont je
suis le délégué général maintenant et
donc je poursuis ce combat de la
pédagogie l'économie pour que les
français comprennent bien sortent un peu
de ces images caricaturales
contre l'entreprise contre le travail
contre le capital contre canton
l'innovation à la koko les gens que les
français comprennent bien que c'est leur
compréhension de 2,2 de cette économie
qui participera de la réussite
économique du pays si c'est on est on
est pas bon si on ne croit pas dans
quelque chose eh bien on ne fait pas
donner le meilleur donc il faut bien que
la france est un des rares pays au monde
à ne pas bien comprendre bien sûr toutes
les règles de pour réussir pour créer de
l'emploi pour pour le pays de la
protection sociale pour voilà et donc
c'est un travail de
penser justement des premières mesures
qui ont été prises par le gouvernement
socialiste auparavant je voudrais tout
de même qu'on aborde la question de la
reconstruction de l'ump va y avoir un
changement à la tête même de l'ump des
élections qui sont prévues 18 et 25
novembre pour les militants vous avez
choisi votre camp françois fillon jean
françois boulier choisie en raison
peut-être aurions parce que j'en sois
fier parce que d'abord la numéro 2 c'est
venir les pécresse
c'est notre président dans les yvelines
qui est une fille
performante qui est fiable qui a réussi
une des réformes les plus difficiles
qu'il a efforts de l'université
brillamment donc c'est une fille mon
avis elle fait partie des dd dans les
femmes je dirais qu'il ya deux femmes
qui m'impressionne en politique c'est
valérie pécresse et christine lagarde
dont vous suivez avec pécresse parce que
ça valérie pécresse mais françois fillon
parce qu'elles forment un beau couple
avec françois fillon parce que françois
fillon pendant cinq ans il a eu cinq ans
dont quatre en crise il s'en est très
bien sortie la protéger les français
efficacement je pense que c'était un des
bons à des bons résultats dans sur ce
pays elle était très bien géré certes y
avait monsieur sarkozy mais de françois
fillon était aux premières loges cinq
ans il a réussi son son son opération
mais pécresse était un de ses principes
ce couple est rassurant monsieur dit
j'aime bien aussi jean françois copé
mais un bon peut-être jean marie guénois
aussi qu'à député de la 3e
circonscription qui a découvert les
yvelines récemment puisqu'il a été élu
donc dans cette troisième
circonscription après un parachutage
mouvementée on va dire on avait
longuement parlé mais finalement donc il
a été il a été élu il a décidé de se
présenter à la tête de l'ump c'est en
politique en vidéo musique parle souvent
de quelque chose qu'ils se sont dit
paraît quelque chose de il ne
connaissent pas je ne connais pas c'est
monsieur guaino pour en parler je sais
que simplement il a est quand même à
l'ombre de nicolas sarkozy orateurs de
monsieur sarkozy est sur un sujet quand
même important c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dire je peux pas en parler en deux
temps par contre
c'est que j'ai vu sur candidature
c'est bien que plusieurs candidats c'est
pas de la campagne partout si lise touya
où il ya même plus de d'élections enfin
je veux dire
c'est le parti socialiste français est
un des derniers partis quand même avec
un fond totalitaire enfin l'un des
derniers pays des deux parties qui n'a
pas coupé que le marxisme tous les
partis socialistes en europe on complète
le marxisme et s'assurer qu'ils sont des
socialistes sur
le mode de scrutin l'ump 8000 signatures
de militants d'adhérent à l'ump
est-ce que c'est pas trop justement ceci
c'est trop fou dans le modifier je pense
qu'il ya eu des commentaires là dessus
il ya débat et 6,6 et romain higuain
quand même pas mal de candidats quand
même maison
ils n'ont pas encore tous les signatures
on verra l'arrivée c'est tout le monde à
toutes les signatures de bruno le maire
jean françois méchain bertrand henri
guaino nathalie kosciusko morizet ou
françois fillon je pense qu'ils auraient
plusieurs candidats et puis vous aurez
un vrai débat déjà entre les deux
principaux candidats il clique comme un
débat assez à ces actifs ont fait une
poussée souris qui pour mener
l'opposition qui pour mener l'ump c'est
la question que nous avons posée
aujourd'hui
bâle un micro-trottoir que nous devrions
retrouver dans un instant mais pour
l'instant nous allons vous écoutez
concernant les mesures justement qui ont
été pris par le par le nouveau pouvoir
nouveau pouvoir socialiste le sénat a
voté jeudi le projet de loi sur le
logement social et qui prévoit la
cession gratuite de terrain de l'état
aux collectivités locales et porte à 25%
le taux obligatoire de logement social
dans les communes sous peine de
pénalités encore plus sévère est ce que
ça c'était une bonne mesure au sénat
l'ump a voté contre sauf un un sénateur
c'était aujourd'hui les 25% les 25%
notamment beaucoup du moins chez à 26%
elle encourt donc
25%
oui mais attention maintenant
attention c'est ce pays est fragile il
faut pas trop le brutaliser il faut il
faut le moderniser il faut le réformer
il faut lui dire la vérité c'est
important de les socialistes
voilà il puis faut pas nier qu'à une
crise il faut il faut pages et il faut
gérer l'europe aussi l'europe et d'une
porte de sortie il faut pas se fâcher
que la merkel que monsieur hollande a pu
se fâcher faut pas toucher aux à la
baisse des aux exonérations des heures
supplémentaires ça nous a sorti du
carcan étouffant des 35 heures c'était
une porte de sortie on y llach la france
qui les 35 heures contre le travail donc
il faut attention nos amis socialistes
doit doivent comprendre les comptes de
l'entreprise les histoires sur le
capital faut arrêter de mettre tous les
riches dehors et sur l'ajustement sur
cette imposition 75% par exemple ce qui
pourrait entraîner le départ de certains
entrepreneurs de france on pourrait
citer l'exemple des collaborateurs de
monsieur loren b 10e même que c'est une
mesure qui embarrasse tout le monde mais
que monsieur hollande a pris cet
engagement pour avoir l'extrême gauche
une mesure d'extrême gauche il n'y a pas
un pays au monde sur 200 pays qui a osé
sortir cette bêtise que un type qui est
riche on lui prend soin de 15% de sang
vous comprenez sont revenus hier par un
trio on comprenait certains
entrepreneurs souhaitent quitter la
france écoutez monsieur me choque pas
monsieur
françois
et
patron de lvmh va partir c'est la
quatrième fortune au monde on voit ce
qu'il a raison non il y là il a créé 80
mille emplois donc il va certainement
partir avec comme avec d'autres parce
qu'on parle
lui
la raison parce qu'il a raison quitté la
france avec cette imposition 75%
mais c'est pas qu'il a raison ou qui a
tort c'est qu'il a de fortes chances de
partir avec beaucoup d'autres il a 80
mille emplois pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
voulez vous restez dans un pays où on
vous méprise en vous stigmatise on vous
raquette parce que ce soit 2 15% c'est
du luxe et du racket je n'y a pas débat
s'ils jouent si vous étiez une situation
vous partiriez on teste des socialistes
que l'on lui et si on prend ça me
rassure c'est encore de la marge et je
vais encore rester quelques instants
tout cas on n'est pas encore sûr c'est
75% d'un président est monsieur long des
treize ans voire l'arrêt de toutes
sortes avec ses propositions qu'il a
fait pour plaire à l'extrême gauche mais
la france n'est pas doit pas être gérée
par l'extrême gauche dire que 50 il fait
dans l'économie vous allez rester en
plateau avec nous à l'iss gastines pour
la chronique de l'écho du jeudi va nous
rejoindre on parlera notamment du statut
d'auto entrepreneur qui avait été créée
sous nicolas sarkozy auparavant
justement je vous le disais tout à
l'heure nous parlions donc de
l'opposition qui pour mener cette
opposition cette fameuse question du
jour là voici mon avis c'est françois
fillon voilà pourquoi parce qu'il a été
très bon premier ministre il a une
meilleure image de marque que tous ceux
qui sont présentés août et ceux qui sont
passés avant lui françois rollin et non
et françois fillon ayant coupé des trucs
que j'ai un copain est plus compétent
que prince of france sauf françois bon
s'appeler ya françois fillon pourquoi
qu'est ce qui fait que le plus gros parc
il est partout frein sopo pays ces deux
mères des se déchirent il se défonce à
moi je préfère fin et il est il est plus
compétent à fillon peut-être
pourquoi fillon
puisque on a déjà fait ses preuves
plus que les autres ben c'était le
premier ministre donc
je pense que là parce que revient de
droit je pense que les différents chefs
comme copé ou fillon je ne peux
paraissent être les mieux classées mais
lequel des deux joueurs seraient
les suivantes les plus petits on va dire
non je pense pas à mon avis n'auront pas
assez de signatures déjà pour être
cooptés et ça va se faire sur montre
l'un des deux